good evening I'm former United States  Senator and recidivist presidential  candidate Mike Gravel out of common  decency and a court order I'm obliged to  warn you that the 3d reason not TV  videos you're about to view are not only  terrifying but real members of the  audience who are susceptible to seizures  high blood pressure and politically  induced rage should exit their browsers  now children pregnant women and fiscally  responsible adults should consult an  account before watching these videos if  you feel your head is about to explode  at any time you may obtain immediate  relief by screaming don't be embarrassed  to open your mouth and let it rip with  all you've got remember they scream at  the right moment just by saving your  life and your country's future